I'm on my way to work in my editorial
office for the first time in eight weeks
for the first time since the Karuna
lockdown but somehow it is quiet on the
streets even though we're allowed to
move around freely many are staying at
home and working from there the
Parisians are probably afraid of the
virus I loop back at 13th of March 20 20
lakh down the Karuna virus is spreading
throughout France many people do not
understand why from one day to the next
it should no longer leave the house my
father and I are aware of the danger
because he is a doctor I still have to
go to my practice patients who have the
corona virus come and I have no
protective equipment that's impossible
the health authorities are supposed to
protect us and they have led us down
that's especially painful
I'm worried at 64 my father is in the
risk group to keep him safe at work they
put a program for remote testing on his
computer every morning he now sees his
patients on the screen many are afraid
they have the virus I think it's highly
unlikely that you've become infected
with the corona virus the situation is
different in hospitals
friends of my father work and crowded
intensive care units the hospital staff
also lacked protective clothing
my father is upset that so many people
are infected several doctors and nurses
have died
[Music]
every evening at 8 p.m. sharp applause
for the doctors and hospital staff our
neighbors want to show support for those
who are risking their lives by fighting
on the front line against the virus
during the day all we can do is cook
meals for once my girlfriend Elaine has
come by she lives with her parents of
three siblings and a 40 square meter
apartment like many Parisians the
streets are empty er than ever the Shan
police say are deserted the death toll
is rising and rising nevertheless we try
to maintain a normal rhythm of life
getting up early every morning we
celebrate my father's 65th birthday as
best we can to establish normality even
when nothing is normal anymore and as
much as I try to talk myself into
accepting house arrest
I'm really feeling closed in I have only
one thing on my mind to get out of Paris
I find an excuse to sneak out of town
early in the morning I want to visit my
mother in the olives on the 600
kilometer drive I see just five cars
I've never seen our country so empty
it's like a science fiction movie
after a five-hour journey I reached my
destination despite the beautiful
landscape my mother is not doing well
either
my grandmother isn't in all people's
home and she has not been allowed to
visit her for weeks she can only talk to
her through the window hello mom I
brought you flowers I can't have
physical contact with her anymore but
that is important to her and I can't
take care of her clothes anymore since
the lockdown I have not brought her any
because I'm afraid I might be carrying
the virus back in Paris my father now
wants to see patients in his practice
again under strict safety rules but he
has to get the masks and other
protective equipment himself on the
internet for a lot of money
but patients are only allowed to come to
the practice if they have an appointment
so no one is allowed to sit in the
waiting room the patients must disinfect
their hands every morning we also have
to clean the floors thoroughly 11th of
May 20-22 eight weeks of lockdown and
more than 25,000 dead we take our first
steps back into everyday life
restaurants remain closed even if the
lockdown is lifted life will not be the
same as before we must be patient
and learn to live with the virus because
the existing restrictions have to take
effect and we all who that are neutral
in a wave will not occur